حمل العام 2022 تحديات اقتصاديه جمع اربكت
حسابات العالم باسره خسائر وديون متراكمه
وفقر يتزايد عام ابتسم بعدم اليقين وفق
مؤشرات البنك الدولي واسهمت بالرؤيه
والمؤشرات الاقتصاديه السلبيه عالميا
الزياده في عدد الكوارث الطبيعيه واشدتها
والتي بينت على نحو جالي الاثار
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه لتغير المناخ اضف
الى ذلك ارتفاع تضخم وانعدام الامن
الغذائي اولى المؤشرات السلبيه كانت تباطؤ
معدلات النمو اذ يشهد الاقتصاد العالمي
اشد معدلات التباطؤ في اعقاب تعافي ما بعد
الركود منذ عام 1970 وتشهد اكبر ثلاث
اقتصادات في العالم وهي امريكا والصين
ومنطقه اليوروباته ان حادا للنمو اما
الفقر خلال عام 2022 فقد شكل الجائحه
كورونا اكبر انتكاسا لجهود الحد منه في
العالم منذ عقود وبحلول نهايه 2022 يمكن
ان يصل الى
685 مليون شخص في فقره ما يجعل 2022 ثاني
اسوء عام على مستوى جهود الحد من الفقر في
العقدين الماضيين بعد 2020 الازمه الاخرى
المديونيه العالميه اذا ارتفعت مستويات
الديون العامه للبلدان الناميه على مدى
العقود الماضيه اذ نحو 60% من الدول
الافقر هي في حاله مديونيه حرجه او معرضه
لتلك المخاطر الوضع ليس افضل كذلك بالنسبه
لاسعار الغذاء وانعدام الامن الغذائي
تشاهد عام 2022 ارتفاعا حادا في انعدام
الامن الغذائي في جميع انحاء العالم
واستجابه للازمه اتاحت مجموعه البنك
الدولي 30 مليار دولار للتصدي لانعدام
الامن الغذائي على مدى 15 شهر شهرا
اجمل اكبر هي في الطاقه شهد النصف الاول
من 2022 واحده من اكبر الصدمات التي شهدها
العالم في اسواق الطاقه العالميه منذ عقود
زادت اسعار الطاقه الزياده كبيره ما ادى
الى تفاقم ونقص بالطاقه وزياده التباطؤ في
حصول الجميع على مصادر طاقه حديثه ميسوره
التكلفه وموثوقه ومستدامه بحلول عام
2020 في هذا الموضوع بالذات وبعد مفاوضات
مضنيه توصلت الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
للاتفاق يحدد سقف اسعار الغاز بعد مفاوضات
استمرت الشهرا حول السعر المناسب وزيره
الطاقه المالطيه مريم ديالي قالت ان
الاتفاق توصل لتحديد سقف للاسعار عند 180
يورو بدلا من 2050 يورو لكل ميجاوات في
الساعه هذا بالتالي يساعد في امتصاص الغضب
المتصاعد في الشارع اوروبي نتيجه ازمه
الطاقه الحاليه الزميل ناصر الطيبي يشرح
لنا بالتفاصيل قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي
بوضعه سقف لسعر الغاز وشروط التط